- Hello everyone. My name's Etienne.
I'm an Edge specialist essay
based from Sydney, Australia.
It's good to be with you here today.
We've traveled a long way to be here.
I'm here with my colleague Nishit
and with my customer Ambrose.
- Thank you. Good morning everyone.
My name's Ambrose Phey and
I'm a cloud network engineer
at Atlassian in our Edge services team.
Today I've flown in from Australia
and I'm excited to share
in our story, use case
and outcomes of the work we've been doing
over the past year with
Amazon's Edge products.
But for now, I'll pass it over to Nishit.
- Hello everyone. I'm Nishit Sawhney.
I'm the director and general manager
for network services at Amazon.
These include Amazon CloudFront,
our Perimeter Protection Services
and Application Load Balancing, ALBs.
- Thank you Nishit.
So you're in session net
211, the state of Edge.
We are excited to share
some insights today
and we glad to bring you along with some
of the journey that
we've been involved with.
We are excited to make sure
that you take away some
of the learnings that Ambrose
and his team have worked
through and we hope you enjoy it today.
This is a 200 level talk.
We expect you to notice something
about CloudFront, WAF and Shield.
However, if you don't
stress, we'll take you along
for the ride.
I'm gonna hand it to Nishit.
- Thank you. All right.
So let's start by defining
what an Edge service is
and what is at the AWS Edge?
Well, an Edge service is a
distributed computing service
that brings network, storage,
compute, capabilities physically closer
to your users, thereby reducing
latency for your users.
Now at AWS, there are
several Edge services
that run either partially
or fully at the Edge.
For the purposes of this
session, we are going
to focus on Amazon
CloudFront, Shield and WAF.
Just as a refresher, CloudFront
is a global content delivery network.
Shield and WAF are security services
that protect your
applications against Layer 3/4
and Layer 7 attacks.
Our mission really is to
protect your applications,
make them fast, secure, and resilient.
If you think about it,
our mission really is
to make the internet fun and engaging
for billions of users across the world.
This is what drives me and my team at AWS.
Now, we've evolved our services
over the last 17 years.
As per the evolution of the internet.
The internet has gone
through massive shifts,
each one redefining
how users interact, what
applications you build,
and what infrastructure services
like ours need to deliver.
Let's start with how it all began.
The web was simple static web,
a browser made a request for a file.
The server responded simple, get requests.
Security was simple, merely IP blocks.
Caching rules were pretty simple.
Along came the transactional
and the e-commerce web.
That's where APIs became
prevalent. Put post requests.
We in CloudFront, launched
dynamic content acceleration
for handing these kind of requests.
Security became more complicated.
DDoS attacks at Layer 3/4
and Layer 7 became prevalent.
Then came the next big shift,
which was social and mobile.
If you think about it,
that really democratized the
internet bringing millions
and millions of users
and scale on the network.
Security then became even more complicated
with bot activity.
These bots acted as humans
and tried to conduct
or steal information from your websites.
Latency also became even more complicated.
Then the next step was really social media
and short form video live streams.
Here, latency attachments
became emotional.
It wasn't just a number it
hundred millisecond latency
difference could be
really the differentiator
between user engagement and
abandonment on a platform
like TikTok or Reels.
Along the right came Internet
of Things here we saw
a lot more devices and a lot more requests
with different traffic
profiles on the internet.
But what came along with
that was opportunities
for those devices to be
compromised by malicious actors
and that created these
massive pool of devices
on endpoints on the
internet that would launch
DDoS attacks and other web
attacks against the applications.
We've evolved our services
along these evolutions
and one such thing
that we did was security
was no longer reactive.
It had to become proactive.
So we launched threat
intelligence built based
on a global set of sensors,
which we call honeypot network.
That Honey Pot Network allows
us to collect intelligence
from the entire web and
feed that intelligence
into our services at AWS and
protect your applications.
So what really happened here was
the perceived latency tolerance
for our users went down.
The security and resiliency
expectations has increased
exponentially, but we are
now entering the next era,
which is the Agentic Web or the AI web.
I'm gonna ask a question, how many
of you have observed requests
on your web applications
that are originating from
AI bots or chat bots?
Quite a few.
This is the data that we see
on websites that are hosted
on CloudFront and AWS WAF.
On a daily basis, billions
of requests are originating from AI bots
like Chatbot, GPT, Claude,
Perplexity, Nova, Bedrock, et cetera.
And this is not just
for certain industries
like retail and e-commerce.
Every possible industry
and customers to the
in those industries are experiencing this.
And you might be wondering,
well, don't we have a way
to solve this with
something called robots.txt?
Well, that really is the challenge.
Robots.txt was built for
an entirely different era.
It was when bots were
well-behaved and respecting,
but the bots have evolved.
The bots used to be traditional bots
for crawl and refer search bots.
They've now increasingly
become AI training bots used
for training massive amounts of data
and models they crawl and consume.
And increasingly we are
seeing agentic AI bots
that are conducting transactions
and actions on behalf of the users.
I hear from a lot of customers, especially
in publishing space, where they're asking
for help to deal with this bot activity.
First of all to understand
what bot activity is
on their websites, to
apply rules that apply
with their business logic,
like allowing those bots denying
or even in some cases monetizing
in a sophisticated manner.
So really the the Agentic
Web era is defined
by three defining trends.
The first one is the
traffic profile is changing.
We see a lot of burst
traffic on our network.
We see a whole bunch of duplex connections
to chat applications.
We see not just large
objects for live streams
and video, but also
tokens that used for LLMs.
Our network needs to evolve for that.
The second big trend is security.
Now customers are asking for security
of their AI based applications,
but also from AI powered attacks.
And lastly, you all developers are going
through an unprecedented era
where the development cycles are so fast.
You can now build applications
with AI coding assistance
or agent systems like Bedrock AgentCore,
or even why coding platforms
like Lovable and Cursor and Kiro.
And you all do not want to be hindered
by infrastructure complexity.
Our customers want the
infrastructure services
to evolve with the pace of
these new development cycles.
We don't want infrastructure
to be in the way.
These three trends are what
are driving our investments
and roadmap at head services.
In the next part of the session, I'm going
to talk about these three trends
and some of the enhancements we've made
and how we've helped customers
as well as where we are going.
Okay, so let's start with
performance and resiliency.
The underpinnings of great
performance, resiliency
and security is the massive AWS network.
This comprises of AWS regions
as well as distributed PoPs
that belong to Amazon CloudFront.
This network has been growing
over 50% year over year.
We've added 750 plus PoPs
and 1,140 embedded PoPs
that are deployed deeply
inside ISP networks.
We are now in 200 plus cities
and 50 plus countries connecting
to millions of users around the world.
This network handles trillions
of requests on a given day
and hundreds and hundreds of
terabytes per second peak.
But that's not just all, even
from a security standpoint,
this network allows us
tremendous amount of data
for threat intelligence purposes.
We analyze exabytes of
data every minute and just
in the last year, we handled
6.2 million DDoS attacks,
which was a growth of 150% year over year.
The largest one being
25 terabytes per second.
Okay, on this network,
we just recently launched
a Global Anycast bring your own IP.
Up until now, when you
put your application
on CloudFront, you would
get dynamically assigned IPs
to your applications.
Last year, we launched
the Anycast capability
with static IPs and
customers could use that
to put their applications allow listed
for enterprise firewalls or
even zero rating agreements
with relation with ISPs.
With the recent launch, you
can now bring your own IP
and enhance that experience.
This BYOIP capability comes
integrated with VPC IPAM
as the unified way in
which you bring IPs to AWS.
Think about what this does.
You now have a global front door, Anycast
on the AWS network.
So let's go into under the hood
of what happens when a
request comes to this network?
Your users are trying
to access applications,
which might be in database
regions or other clouds
or on-premise networks.
When request hits the database
Edge, the CloudFront PoP,
there's TLS termination
and the TLS optimizations
that happen through there.
We optimize routing to the best PoP
from a latency point of
view, and we get millions
of measurements on real time latency data
from web bugs that are
deployed across the world.
That allows us to route your
requests to the best PoP.
And we handle congestion on the network
as part of this routing.
Your dynamic content or APIs go
over the privately managed backbone,
the database backbone,
straight to your regions,
to your applications.
For cacheable content,
it goes through a series
of tiered caches on the AWS network.
These caches are on the AWS PoPs
as well as in regions in AWS.
Optionally, customers
configure Origin Shield, which
is yet another layer of caching
that allows better offload
and better performance through
persistent connections back
to your origins.
Now as we've seen, a lot
of our customers want
to customize and
personalize their delivery.
We've added capabilities
like CloudFront functions
and Lambda Edge over the years, along
with a global key value store
that allows you to do AB testing
or manipulate request
response capabilities
on your requests.
This again allows you
to put compute closer
to where your users are
and reduce the latency
that they experience.
Over the years, we've added a lot
of performance enhancements
to different parts
of the request flow.
One such enhancement was
QUIC/HTTP3 launched in 2023.
QUIC/HTTP3 originally from
Google allows faster time
to First Byte and leads to TCP head
of line blocking removal.
What it does is it combines the TLS
and the HGTP Handshake
into single connection.
Over 25% of requests on
platform today are on QUIC,
and this is something that
is available just by default.
Last week, we added another capability
for enhancing the
performance of QUIC/HTTP3.
We added support for HTTPS DNS records.
Now this is a DNS record
type that allows us
to send hints about
supported HTTP protocols
as part of DNS query itself.
Let's understand what that means.
When your client
or browser session requests an IP address
for your application hosted on CloudFront,
it makes the DNS query and
that's where it gets the A
or quad, a address of the CloudFront PoP.
Your browser then establishes a TCP TLS
and a CTP connection with CloudFront.
That connection happens
over HTP 1.1 or 1.2.
Then CloudFront provides a
clue to your browser saying
We support HTTP3 as part
of all service headers.
That leads to an additional handshake
and round trip time when
connecting to the optimal protocol.
What with the launch of HTTPS DNS records
in the query itself, the
DNS query itself you,
we will pass support for HTTP3 as a signal
when you now make the
connection to CloudFront.
It comes with already the
optimal protocol selection
of HTTP3.
This has been a huge
hit as it leads not just
to performance benefit,
but also DNS query cost reduction
because alias records on
Route 53 are free of charge.
There's some other enhancement
that we made on round trip reduction.
Let me walk through two of those.
The first one is TLS 1.3 to Origin.
We just launched this
capability that allows you
to establish TLS 1.3 origins connections
between CloudFront and
your supported origins.
So if you have your origins
that support TLS 1.3, this just works.
We've seen almost 36%
improvement in handshake time.
As with TLS 1.3, it cuts
the round trip connections
for TLS exchange.
The second one is TCP Fast open
TCP Fast Open allows data to be sent
as part of HTCP SYN exchange.
We've added support for this
and observed 50% improvement
in TCP Connect times.
This is available between CloudFront PoPs
and our internal caching layers.
Again, works by default.
The best part about these
performance enhancements are
that they are enabled by default.
They just work and they're free.
So I would recommend
that you look at these
and see if these apply to you, especially
as TLS 1.3 and HTTP DNS records
and take advantage of these
with your application delivery.
Okay, we are now going to switch
to this next part, which
is building a secure Edge.
I'm gonna invite Etienne
to walk you through that.
- Thank you Nishit, for
all the work that you
and your team put together
to improve the performance
for our customers.
So I'd like to talk a little bit about
how we provide Security Edge,
what you can do and what is
provided to you by default
when you use CloudFront.
So Nishit described a little bit about
how the request path happens
through our infrastructure
and I'm going to talk in
a little bit more detail
about what we do at the Edge.
So typically at an Edge
Location, we provide connection
from there back to an
AWS origin, which may be
a load balancer or it could be
to your on-premise location.
With that type of
connection, we can provide
to AWS origins using VPC Origins
where we can ingress traffic
into a private subnet,
thereby reducing the the tax
surface, reducing the need
for public load balances
and recently just launched
is cross account VPC origin support.
So you can actually use
almost a hub and spoke model
for using CloudFront to
route into private subnets
across multiple accounts.
Again, we have origin access control
to help protect your
access from CloudFront
to something like Lambda
URLs or your buckets
and some of our media services.
So when traffic come comes to
your CloudFront distribution,
CloudFront will provide a TLS certificate
for someone to connect to.
Right now we've actually
just launched MTLS support,
so a client can provide a certificate
and authenticate that way as well.
On top of that, the team
have enabled post quantum
cryptography support or cipher supports.
And so what this means is that
by default, when you use
CloudFront, you're future proofed
for that type of attack risk.
On top of that, CloudFront
provides the ability
to protect against Layer 3
and layer of war attack
vectors by using Shield.
This helps you protect against
issues on known offenders
and provides a SIM proxy.
There's continuous inspection at the Edge
and there's protocol validation
and packet validation.
There are automated routing policies
for particular large attacks so
that it helps mitigate the risk
away from your applications.
CloudFront also provides
the ability to monitor
and check the resource application usage
at the Edge so that we can
make sure that attack surfaces
that would be vulnerable to Solaris
and HTTP/2 Rapid Reset are negated.
There's further protections
that you could have with using AWS WAF.
You can elect to turn this on
on your platform distribution.
Here you can use controls
such as rate limiting
by aggregate key employ
Amazon managed rules such
as the anti-DDoS rules
and our Amazon partner Edge
and managed rules as well.
You can build your own custom
rules and use bot control
and fraud control rule sets at the Edge.
So let's talk a little
bit about bot control
and fraud control.
Our Anti-DDoS rule set allows you
to very quickly turn on protections
to protect your application
against volumetric attacks.
This is something that you can tune
and we'll talk a little bit
more detail about this later.
With AWS WAF bot control,
you can choose two different
types of modes of operation
to protect against common
bots that are easily detected
through common signatures
and then looking at behavior
and machine learning
capability with targeted bots.
These are for sophisticated bots.
We'll talk a little bit more
about some of the innovations
that the team have introduced.
On top of that,
we have our account takeover
fraud prevention rule sets
and our account creation
fraud prevention rule sets.
These are particularly
helpful when you want to deal
with credential stuffing attacks or
if you have a particular
benefit when someone wants
to sign up an account,
but there's a financial
benefit or a scraping benefit
that someone would want
to take advantage of
and these would help
provide you the controls
at the Edge of the network
to prevent that risk.
So let's talk about anti-DDoS rules
and how these rules reduce
their attack surface.
DDoS attacks When I've
helped customers mitigate
these DDoS attacks, rate
controls alone are not sufficient
and so you would want
to not spend time going
through your logs and
trying to figure out how
to put these protections at the Edge just
with simple IP controls.
What you can do is use
the anti-DDoS rule set
and which is quite quick to deploy
and within a few minutes you
can have an effective control.
What's really neat about this is
that you can tune this
rule set based on the type
of workload you have and your appetite
for absorbing a certain amount of traffic.
Typically, you would want to make sure
that this rule set sits in the top part
of your rules so that
it's exposed to as much
of the traffic signature as possible.
This allows you to tune the rule sets,
decide which path you want to protect.
You can scope these protections,
you can add exclusion lists.
There may be parts of your own application
that you don't want this
control in place for.
And then there's a rich set of metrics
that are emitted into
CloudWatch that you can then use
to drive alarms and to be
able to build some dashboards
to understand the type of
DDoS risk that you're facing.
This helps you make sure that
you can more quickly adapt
and mitigate for your volumetric attacks
and improve the accuracy
of your DDoS mitigations.
There's a challenge capability
in the anti DDoS rules
that allow you to have
a conditional action
to help prove out that someone
is a valid user or not.
And the granular controls allow you
to change your rule sets based on the risk
that you're facing at
any one point in time.
You may have an appetite
that you would have
a lower risk profile during a large event
and you may have a more,
less of an appetite
during a large event.
Yeah. Alright, pivoting to
what we've recently released,
which is mutual TLS or mutual
transport layer security
authentication, which
is a security protocol
that extends the standard
TLS authentication into a
bidirectional certificate
based authentication.
If you've not yet used this,
what this simply means is
that a client provides a
certificate to help prove
that it's who it's and
CloudFront has two modes
of operation where you can
allow for both standard traffic
with a normal certificate
and out of mutual TLS
and TLS mutual TLS only.
This allows you to migrate
between the two models.
We're quite excited to see
what our customers do with us
and please have a look at this capability.
I'm personally quite excited
about what we we are doing
in the space with Agentic
in the agentic internet era,
and this is an additional capability.
It was recently launched.
What we have found is that businesses
are facing an onslaught
of traffic via agents.
And what this means is
that you potentially need
to be able to have not only
just a control at the Edge,
but you also need to have
a rich set of metrics.
Bot control's at the center of this.
And this allows you to make sure
that legitimate AI agents
can access your distribution
through a process of a
cryptographic control.
And this allows you to then
to create fine tune controls
for your AI agents to
access specific parts
of your application whilst
denying access to others.
It of us have these managed rules
that allowed that automatically
allow verified bots plus
blocking unverified traffic.
So the first step is to make sure
that you can identify the risk
and then decide what you want to mitigate.
This is done through both categorization
or through the simple AI
label that you can choose
which specific bot you want to block.
With web bot authentication,
you'll be able
to allow your application
to be more deeply integrated
into your WAV to make sure that
those parts can be monetized
if you choose to.
So there's an additional
level of capability that
is continuously being built on
and will keep adding to
this capability and time.
Now I'd like to hand back to Nishit
to talk a little bit about some
of the work the team are doing
to help improve our develops lives.
- Thank you.
As part, this is my favorite part,
so let's talk about security.
Now, lots of customers tell
us that configuring security
in this ever evolving landscape is hard,
but it does not need to be hard.
This is an area that we
are massively investing
in solving this challenge.
Earlier this year, we re-imagined
a developer experience
for configuring security rules
with CloudFront and ALBs.
Here you can add WAF capabilities
as part of protection packs.
These are tailored rules and rule sets
that are designed for
your traffic profile.
It comes with vis improved
visibility as well
as easier, more intuitive
configuration controls.
We are adding more capabilities here
to bring smarter recommendations
and automated traffic analysis
on these rollbacks in future.
Already with these enhancements we've seen
about 80% reduction in the
initial configuration steps
and a dramatic improvement
in the success rate
for customers configuring
their security rules
on the front doors.
Now here's another favorite part of mine.
Developer complexity is not
just technical complexity,
it is also pricing complexity.
When CloudFront was launched back
in 2008, we disrupted
the CDN pricing industry
with pay as you go pricing.
Customers could simply use the CDN
and pay as their traffic grew
and the pricing scaled accordingly.
But over the years, customers have told us
that while they like the
pay as you go pricing model,
they're worried about bill shocks.
They might see their websites
either getting really popular
and viral and it would lead
to sudden increase in bills
or they might get hot
linked or even suffer
from DDoS attacks that might lead
to exponential request charges.
We've solved that problem with
what we call flat-rate pricing plans,
and this was launched two weeks ago.
It basically starts with $0 pricing plans
that include not just CloudFront,
but security services,
Amazon S3, Route 53,
CloudWatch Ingestion, ACM,
and a bunch of other services.
These pricing plans come
with no overages whatsoever.
You pay a fixed monthly price
or you start with $0 free plan.
And then you upgrade to these
according to your growth
of your business, but you
never would see overage
or unpredictable pricing anymore.
There's no long term commitments either.
In just a week or so since
launch, tens of thousands
of customers are using,
taking benefit of these plans
and serving their applications.
Something that if you haven't looked at,
I would encourage you to take a look.
Right, another great simplification
is CloudFront SaaS Manager.
Lots of our customers
host millions of domains
or hundreds of thousands of domains in
multi-tenant applications.
The vibe coding platforms like
Cursor, Lovable, et cetera,
also allow customers to
build applications with lots
of multi-tenant domains and and tenants.
Up until this time, you would have
to create individual distributions
and apply policies such as cash policies
or security policies individually
on those distributions.
With CloudFront SaaS Manager,
it provides a unified way
and a dramatically simpler experience
in which you can handle
multi-tenant applications
on the AWS Edge.
You can apply template policies
that can apply on the
entire list of tenants,
or you can override
certain specific policies
because of you may have some
premium set of customers
and you know, other tiers of customers.
This is again, one of
the great simplifications
that we are evolving.
This was the first step
and we are adding more capabilities such
as tenant specific analytics and reports.
Great, to learn about the
real world applications
of the services and
enhancements we talked about.
I would like to invite
Ambrose from Atlassian.
- Thank you Nishit.
I'm excited to be sharing in the ways
in which Atlassian has leveraged
CloudFront, WAF and Shield
to improve our global security footprint
alongside some useful
patterns we have found
in our widespread adoption journey.
To give some background,
Atlassian as a whole aims
to unlock the potential in every team.
We do so by offering our
applications across a variety
of collections, but all on the
goal to help teams organize,
communicate, and collaborate
around shared work.
Some commonly used applications
you might have seen
before include Confluence
for information sharing.
Jira for project and issue tracking.
Loom for asynchronous video messaging.
Bitbucket for code hosting
and Rovo, our AI powered suite
of applications and agents connected
to the Atlassian platform.
As of today, Atlassian now serves millions
of customers globally across
a wide range of industries.
Atlassian's come a really long way
from when we first launched in 2002.
Over the years, we've released
and acquired many products
and even went public back in 2015.
Now, in 2016, Atlassian
began the journey to move all
of its workloads to be
fully hosted in the cloud.
And as of 2022, we completed this journey.
As of today, we handle tens of billions
of requests over tens of thousands
of EC2 instances across
13 different regions,
handling multiple petabytes of data out
to clients every single day.
But that's not the end of our story.
Over the years, the team
has continued to improve
and develop upon its cloud posture
and architecture leading
to our resultant migration
of our largest products.
Duran Confluence onto CloudFront.
Now, Atlassian already
has a really long running
history with CloudFront.
We've invested several years
and deployed thousands of distributions.
This figure here shows a
historical high level view
of a request flow on what a
page load might look like.
Dynamic requests land on
a network load balancer
towards our ingress proxies
before getting routed to a number
of different upstream services.
And CloudFront accelerating
our static front end
and single page application
delivery across the company.
As of today, every single page load
on every Atlassian product
uses CloudFront in some way.
And to add to that, we were
already using a mixture
off the shelf and internally technologies
to mitigate inauthentic
and malicious requests.
So with that, what more
were we looking to achieve?
Building on our rich experience
with CloudFront, we wanted
to leverage it beyond just
acting as a basic CDN.
We still had not yet
adopted this infrastructure
of the delivery of our first fragment
or primary domains on our major products.
And so our goals of moving Jira
and Confluence in the
CloudFront were multifaceted.
We wanted to strengthen our
global security footprint
against growing sophistication
in modern attacks
and compliance regimes.
Deploy a layered defense at the Edge,
leveraging a consistent
control plane to help
with operational burden, identify common
and shared logic in our application,
which we could perform
closer to our customers.
And finally, improve our
last mile performance
for our end users.
Now potentially you might be thinking
if a large portion of our goals
were pertaining to security,
why not just place WAF on
our existing load balances?
And that would be a good question.
Firstly, as network load
balances are a Layer 3,
Layer 4 construct, WAF logic
just doesn't belong there.
And whilst we could have attached them
to our application load balances,
this would've still left
our ingress proxies needing
to do a lot of the heavy
lifting to mitigate inauthentic
and malicious requests.
We wants to push this defense
beyond the compute
infrastructure we managed.
With that in mind, the
journey of getting Jira
and Confluence onto
CloudFront would pose quite
a unique challenge.
As it would need to handle
orders of magnitude more traffic
than any previously existing
CloudFront distribution.
Accommodate logic to support
customer data distributed
across 13 different regions,
be able to host millions
of customer domains and customer sites,
and finally support an
architecture which aligned
with our customer's security requirements.
All in all, this would
prove to be more involved
than just changing where a record pointed
and required us to use some
of CloudFront's newest features.
One of the big questions
before even moving
to CloudFront was to identify
how we could differentiate ourselves
amongst other CloudFront customers.
To build some context,
Atlassian has a variety
of customers who might
operate their workstations
or API integrations under
strict egress controls.
Others might be doing something similar
to this figure where they
leverage split tunnel VPNs
or secure web gateways to ensure
that our products are only accessible
from their corporate IPs.
Such customers require
that their cloud SaaS
provider present itself
on the internet from a predefined
list of IPs, not cohabited
with any other SaaS
software, allowing them
to perform enterprise
application allow listing.
Typically when you use
CloudFront, your distribution will
use a rotating pool of IP
addresses to serve traffic from.
As you can imagine, this
would pose quite a problem
for our customers as
there'll be no clear way
to differentiate ourselves
amongst other CloudFront services,
other services sitting behind CloudFront.
But this is exactly where CloudFront's,
Anycast static IP feature came into play.
By leveraging this new feature
on our CloudFronts, we
were able to dedicate a set
of IPs across our
CloudFront distributions,
allowing ourselves to
be uniquely identifiable
against other CloudFront customers.
This was a massive UN blocker
in unlocking the transition
of Jira and Confluence onto CloudFront.
As many customer network
policies just would not have been
compatible with CloudFront's traditional
shared dynamic IP space.
With the confidence
that we had a unique way
to present ourselves, our eyes
turned to protection building
on our previous experience, we
launched the Shield Advanced
and layer seven application
protection feature enabled.
This enables WAF and CloudFront
to intelligently catch DDoS attacks.
We then combine this with managed rules
for anti-DDoS, common web attacks.
IP reputation lists alongside
a variety of rate limits.
Now, when crafting your managed rules,
it can sometimes be overwhelming trying
to decide which rules
should go in what order,
and this figure here
is a fantastic example
and mental model approach to use,
but you might need to do
something a bit more bespoke
to your environment.
What we have found to
be effective for us is
by layering our rules
in the following order.
First, label any traffic
that you might want
to apply modifications
or exclusions against
in different policies in your chain.
So these might be for
trusted IPs, countries
or even specific clients.
Next come your strict blocking rules.
So these might be your
known blocking conditions
or managed rules or common web attacks.
Nearly behind those come
your course grain rate limits
and custom rules.
And finally, your IP
reputation list pushing
out silent challenges and captures.
Now I wanna take a second
to call out the managed
anti-DDoS rule set.
This is something you
might want to put earlier
in your rule chain, and
we've seen this being
incredibly effective
at stopping the initial
and largest wave of attacks
in a matter of seconds.
It's also paired really well with Shield
in blocking the remaining trail
of malicious requests.
All of this combined has allowed us
to help create a cost-effective
protection funnel
at the network Edge.
As part of all of this, you'll likely need
to perform some tuning.
This typically is quite
an iterative process
and does require both time and patience.
As per this figure, it is recommended
to first implement your
rules set into count mode,
allowing you the opportunity
to observe and adjust any logic
before promoting it to a
block or challenge action.
In our case, some
interesting tuning scenarios
included confluence pages with .conf, MD
or Java exceptions in them.
Others included scenarios
where customers would put bits
of source code or program outputs
into their pages, searches
or even Jira ticket
comments and descriptions.
The result of all of this work though,
is we're now blocking
hundreds of thousands
of requests now made by bots and scanners.
As well as the occasional 10
and hundred million DDoS attack.
Another capability that Atlassian provides
to its customers is something
commonly referred to
as data residency.
This gives organizations the ability
to choose where the application
data is hosted, such
as whether the data is
globally distributed
or stored in a defined
geographic location such
as the EU or the US.
This is particularly important
in regulated industries
where customers need
to meet a number of data
management requirements.
So using this figure as a
example to help paint a picture.
Let's say we have a company
whose confluence tenant resides
in the EU, but they might
have employees living
in the US, previously requests would land
on the nearest ingress proxy to them.
So let's say in Virginia,
before getting routed cross-region
to their backend tenant in the EU.
Bringing our attention back
to CloudFront, we wanted
to find a way to optimize our ability
to route our customer requests
to their respective data
tables, which could be located
in one of our 13 different regions.
This is exactly where the
origin control helper method
for CloudFront functions came into play.
Now leveraging CloudFront functions
and this new helper method, we were able
to implement logic where we take
a customer's site name, look them up
in a key value store to
identify their backend region
and subsequently steer traffic directly to
that customer's backend tenant.
We were still able to route traffic
to the closest possible region where
that made sense, such as
for loading common front-end
components and assets.
In a to in total across
a number of experiences,
we saw improvements in
our time-to-first-byte,
but more importantly, for
requests that were region steered,
we managed to completely
remove cross-region charges
and benefit from a zero rating of data out
between AWS regions and CloudFront.
Resulting in some very
natural cost optimizations.
Now with the mention of cost savings,
you're probably wondering, but how much?
Well here are the results.
Each color in this graph is representing
an individual region and
in total is representing
the stacked total cost over time.
As you can see, we've seen
significant reductions
in our data transfer out fees
thanks to the zero rating
between Amazon regions and CloudFront.
We've also seen similar reductions
in our cross-region fees thanks
to CloudFront doing the work
of determining the data residency region.
Additionally, we enjoy zero rated requests
to CloudFront that get
blocked by WAF opposed
to if they were blocked on an ALB.
This region steering feature has been
so well received across the company
that we've had many requests
from teams across Atlassian
to help provide similar
functionality to their services too.
So all this combined now means
that we're delivering a more
secure experience presented
behind unique static IPs and
we're leveraging CloudFront
to pull data from the
correct origin region,
all the whilst saving money doing it.
How amazing is that?
Before I move on to the
next section, I want
to share some additional notes
that we've learned along the way.
First, if you're using
a network load balancer
as your origin, make sure
your proxies return the HCTP
connection close header
during draining events.
This can help prevent
some surprising connection
terminations on in-flight requests
as your proxy scale in.
This isn't a problem with
application load balances,
as they'll add the header for you
to tell CloudFront to close
the connection gracefully.
Next CloudFront supports
the use of stale-if-error
and stale-while-revalidate
cache-control directives.
These respectively let
you serve stale cache data
during transient errors
and allow CloudFront
to asynchronously update its cache,
reducing latency spikes and origin calls.
Finally, a low hanging fruit
to improved performance.
Look to tune your origin
keep alive timeouts
where appropriate to benefit most
from persistent connections.
For us, this has helped us yield
around 100 to 150 millisecond speedups.
In parallel to all of this work,
the team also wanted to find a way
to improve the observability
we had at the network Edge.
CloudFront itself comes
out of the box with a range
of different metrics and logging
and these might range from
giving us insights into our users
are coming from, the types of
requests that we're getting
and even the responses
that we're sending back.
But these are all from the
perspective of CloudFront.
Our team wanted
to enhance the visibility
we had into the network
and enrich our overall view.
This is exactly where
network error logging came
into play.
For a little background,
network error logging is
a client side mechanism
that is supported by
a variety of browsers,
particularly Chrome and
Chromium, which can generate
and send reports about network issues
as seen from the client side.
As members of the network Edge, this data
about the availability
off our Edge as seen
by our clients, can be incredibly
valuable when diagnosing
a variety of network issues,
including ones about issues
that might never reach our infrastructure.
So what did this implementation look like?
Believe it or not, it
wasn't overly complex.
By getting our reverse
proxies to add the report to
and any NEL headers on
all client responses,
we can tell supported browsers
where the report errors to.
Leveraging CloudFront
to access a globally accessible endpoint.
We run a Lambda@Edge function to intercept
and process all requests
to be sent towards a Kinesis endpoint
before further processing
by our observability
and monitoring services.
This architecture allows
us to leverage CloudFront
and Lambda@Edge to serverless process
these network error logs into Kinesis.
And this enhanced visibility
has already proved useful
when investigating low
grade and network failures.
One example of this was when
we were investigating an
intermittent TCP reset
issue impacting a percentage
of customers across a random country.
These errors were occurring
before requests even reached our
CDN infrastructure.
But thanks to our serverless
network error logging
architecture, we were able
to gain insights on failed
requests that were not
yet visible from our
CloudFront metrics or logs.
This information has helped
us accurately identify,
start times, error rates,
affected clients geolocations
and the exact TCP error itself.
By collaboratively working
with Amazon, this allowed us
to confidently and accurately
identify the root cause
of this connection issue
pertaining to a network change
outside our own infrastructure.
Alright, we've talked about WAF, Shield
and a few different ways we're
using CloudFront distributions
across a range of our
products and services.
There's one last product
that the CloudFront team has
shipped that I would like to
share how the team is looking
to use, not just scale our services,
but also scale the operational
effectiveness of our team.
Everything I've discussed so far has been
to do with standard distributions.
These distributions are singular
and contain all the settings
pertaining to origin, configs,
cache behaviors and security settings.
What that has meant for us is that
by deploying these distributions
in front of variety
of our products has been an
involved task between members
of our Edge team and our service
owners, where we provision
the distribution for them
and then begin this dance
of collaborative effort to
transition traffic across, tune
a variety of security rules and just
in general smooth out the rough edges.
With that in mind, Atlassian has thousands
of ancillary services which
range from supporting features
and functionality on our main product
to the purposes of internal tooling.
This approach of standard
distributions just did not scale
with our DevOps model
and philosophy of you
build it, you run it.
On top of that, operating
and managing thousands
of distributions at scale
in a conjoined way just
created too much friction.
We were hitting service
limits, account limits,
and it was going to be
too operationally painful
to issue out current level configuration
for these shared distributions.
We really just wanted a
way to have the flexibility
of enforcing a strict base configuration
that the Edge team could
manage, control and roll out.
Whilst allowing our
service owners the ability
to own and run their own
CloudFronts without needing
to be CloudFront experts.
This is exactly where
CloudFront SaaS Manager played
a huge role in unblocking
this operational nightmare.
CloudFront SaaS Manager
has a construct called
multi-tenant distributions, which act
as a parent template for
child distribution tenants
to inherit.
This effectively gave us a
really clean demarcation point
for what and how our team
manages the global configuration
that we expect all distribution
templates to adhere to.
Whilst was giving our service
owners the flexibility
and the ability to load perimeters
into these defined templates
to define customer origins, domains,
and even apply customizations
to their specific distribution WAF.
So in practice, how did this look like?
We deployed numbers of
distribution tenants based
on use case to IMP to
help improve reliability
and reduce blast radius,
including the addition
of a canary style template
to soak initial changes on.
Next, we integrated a service broker
for our service owners to interact with.
Which provisions a distribution
tenant on behalf of them.
This additional broker
also helps us enforce final
base configuration elements,
which we want to restrict
our service owners
from having the flexibility to adjust such
as specific inclusions
of WAF rules we want permanently enforced.
As a result, this will pave the way
for our ancillary services
and their service owners
to onboard onto CloudFront
and WAF, being able to
do so in a self-service
and self-managed model.
Leading to increased speed
of CloudFront adoption
and allowing our developers
to focus on building more
features at the Edge,
possibly handholding of
individual CloudFront adoptions.
As I look to wrap up, I want to reiterate
on a couple of key takeaways.
First, look to leverage CloudFront's new
Anycast static IP feature in scenarios
where your customers have
specific firewall requirements.
In multi-origin and
region scenarios, think
of how you can leverage the new
origin control helper method
to steer traffic to different origins.
This can potentially help reduce
or even avoid cross-region
data transfer fees.
When you need a scalable
multi-domain solution whilst
keeping configuration and
infrastructure simple.
Consider the use of
CloudFront SaaS Manager.
And finally, Ben, a principal engineer
in our team has open sourced
the Python Lambda function,
which prepares CloudFront
logs sent to S3 for Kinesis.
This can help save a lot
of money versus realtime logs at scale.
Finally, I'd like to just say
thank you for taking the time
to listen to our story and our journey
and I hope you've all found
something useful to take away.
But for now, I'll pass it back to Etienne.
- Alright, thank you
everyone for having a listen.
We hope that you've
enjoyed today's session.
I just wanna highlight that
we have a number of sessions
that will dive a lot more deeply
into a number of the topics
that we've discussed today.
I'd encourage you to look them up.
This is worth taking a photograph of.
If it's too small, have a search
for any session that starts
with NET and that will
get you in the realm
of these sessions.
Lastly, I'd encourage you to go build.
It's never been a a better time
to go build with CloudFront
and especially when you start
layering in Shield and WAF.
Thank you again for your time today
and please provide some feedback for us.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)